hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel I'm gonna show you my
favorite knots these are the most useful
knots that everyone should know that you
can use in everyday life whether you're
camping or hiking or just mucking around
the house alright the first thing I want
to show you really isn't an outdoorsy
not it's not that I used around the
house all the time
it's a knot design for storing chords
and ropes and stuff so you get this big
gob of extension cord or rope that's
just sitting in your garage and it's all
tangled up this is a knot that'll help
you store it and get at it quickly and
keep everything nice and tidy
now this knot is called the chain Senate
or the daisy chain or monkey braid it's
very simple make a loop you reach
through the loop you pull out another
loop you reach through that loop you
pull out another loop you reach through
that loop and you pull out another loop
loop it's it's like a magic drink you
just keep going and it makes it's like
crocheting for men so makes this and
then when you pull it it just all comes
out and you can make the loops yes big
or as small as you want and the smaller
they are the kind of the more it stays
together and the more line you take up
shortens rope down to about a third of
its length so if you have a 100-foot
rope and you go and you make a daisy
chain out of it you'll have about 33
foot of days chain you can see there and
it's you know it doesn't really fall
apart or anything and then you just pull
out as much as you need then
when you're done you just go back and
recreate the day's chain just our back
where you left off if you're gonna do
the daisy chain with an electrical cord
start with the male prong and then work
your way down this 100-foot extension
cord goes down to about 30 feet hang it
up on the wall and then keeps it out of
the way so easy to use and pull out as
much or as little as you want just retie
up when you're done now if you're in a
situation where you need an adjustable
length of rope like you're stringing up
a tarp or are putting up a tent we were
often taught in Boy Scouts to use the
taut line and hitch or the midshipman's
knot as its called
but I've got something better and the
reason why it's better is because it's
faster not just it's not faster to tie
it it's faster to take down so this
right here is the Ferryman's friction
hitch it's a little bit stronger than
the taut line hitch or the midshipman's
knot you can put more force on it
without the loop closing but the real
advantage is that it's so easy to take
apart so it's time to break down camp or
take that tarp down take seconds this
knot allows you to adjust the length of
a rope by adjusting the size of the loop
at the end of the rope and the Rope is
slack you can adjust the knot and make
the loop bigger or smaller which
shortens or lengthens the length of the
rope this knot is perfect for situations
where you want to adjust the length of
the rope without having to retie the
knots so the way you tie it is you make
this little loop that you see here and
then you take that side the left side of
the loop and wrap it around itself three
times forming this little hole and you
take the tag end and you pull it halfway
through forming a Bight and then you
cinch it up you pull on it on the the
working end of the the rope then you
grab the knot in these two places those
two places exactly and you pull it and
that tightens the knot this not going to
take a lot more pressure than the
taut-line knot and it comes undone by
just pulling the tag in what I think is
the biggest disadvantage of the Ferriman
friction hitch and the taut line
hitch and the midshipman's not is that
you can only adjust them when they're
not under load so while you're pulling
on them like this you've got something
pressure on it's you can't really adjust
the length of it you can't use it very
effectively to tighten something up a
little bit but but not much okay if you
want to be able to really tighten down
on something if you want to really
basically use a knot version of a
ratchet strap then you're gonna want
this not the trucker's hitch or the
power clinch knot all right so let me
show you the trucker's hitch this is a
great knot for tightening down loads for
putting your knot under tension so you
take this and you make a loop and think
that we're gonna make a slipknot
and what you do is you take your line
you wrap it around okay and you feed it
through and it creates a pulley system
go and really crank this down you can
put a lot of tension on here and then
once you got it tight you pinch this
through your thumb don't let it slip and
then you come through and tie
a half-hitch
and if needs be you can come back and do
another one and that is the trucker's
hitch or the power clinch knot and it is
a fabulous knot to learn if you don't
have ratchet straps if you need to tie
something down or string a hammock this
is fabulous
there's another way to do this you can
go and pinch this down
you can do it like that you see here
there's a there's a bite and then you
want to do it all you got to do this the
whole thing comes and done if you want
your rope super tight this is the knot
for you I use it on trailers for tying
things to the roof of my car but I also
use it for stringing up a hammock so you
can get it just really tight and it's
even strong enough to hold my fat butt
so 250 pounds there you go okay now I'm
going to show you the bowline knot which
is a great knot for putting a loop on
the end of a line when you don't want
that loop to cinch up it's a strong knot
it's easy to tie it's easy to untie and
you can even tie it one-handed so one of
the most common mistakes with the
bowline knot is that when you make this
loop you've got to make it this way with
this part on top if you make it like
this and you do everything else exactly
right it just comes apart so remember
you got to flip it up now another common
mistake with the bowline knot is people
will come down and around and do this so
you've got one line in one light out and
it basically ends up collapsing into a
separate not okay and it's not a
catastrophic failure but remember flip
the loop on top comes up around and down
this is where you hear the things about
you make the hole and the rabbit comes
out of his hole he goes around the tree
and he goes back down his hole that's
the bowline knot this knot is really
easy to undo even if it's been under a
lot of strain so this is a great knot to
use in combination with the trucker's
hitch and because the loop doesn't cinch
up it's great for tying a rope around a
person
okay now you're ready next I'm going to
show you the constrictor knot there's
two ways to tie this knot one is the
loop method where you make these two
loops just like I'm demonstrating here
and then you slide it over the end of
something like the end of a bag or the
end of a post and you just tighten it up
like that or you can do it
the tagging method where you just wrap
it over itself once then over the top
then tuck it under both parts and then
cinch it up the constrictor knot
squeezes things together but is easy to
undo so it's great for bundling up a
bunch of fishing rods for transportation
easy to tie pretty quick and easy to
undo it also works good for tying
together a bunch of two by fours or if
you've got a bunch of rakes in the back
of your pickup truck but it's also if
you grab in the right place it comes
apart pretty quickly and easily this is
also a knot that's used for closing up
the end of a bag so if you've got bags
of fertilizer in your garage and you
don't have any twisty ties then you can
just take a bit of twine and do a
constrictor knot also works good on
children keeps them in line and yeah and
when you're left babysitting the
children a constrictor knot and a
bedsheet will make playtime a lot more
fun now I'm going to show you two ways
of tying a cow hitch knot one is you
wrap a loop around something then feed
the tag end through the loop and you can
use this for a lot of different things
everything from attaching fishing
leaders to swivels to attaching rope to
a piece of equipment it's very versatile
or you can do it a cow hitch knot that's
attached to the its own rope and S forms
a noose that will cinch up very tightly
and so this is great because the loop
collapses on itself and will grip
whatever it's tied around very tightly
but what's really nice about this is no
matter how tight you squeeze that knot
it is extremely easy to untie just give
yourself a little slack in the loop and
then you just push downward on those two
parts and push the loop off and no
matter how tight that knot is it'll come
up easily so I use this on hammocks
because otherwise the knots are hard to
get off
so another knot that's really good is
the half hitch or the double half hitch
so you can see here it's really similar
to what I just tied only you do the
second half backwards and this will also
cinch up and and work pretty well but
it's not as easy to untie as the cow
hitch knot the reason why I like this
knot and why I'm including it is because
you can do a quick release version of it
so it starts off just like the the
double half hitch or the cow hitch knot
then you put a bite in it like this
cinch that up and there you go you've
got a knot that cinches up and acts like
the cow hitch knot but then it's
quick-release okay so it's a nice little
little version and if you want to be
able to take a knot down really quickly
so when I use a fair man's friction
hitch I tie this knot on to the other
end of the line so it's a quick release
knot that's not adjustable so when I got
the Ferryman's friction hitch and on the
other end I've got the double half hitch
with a bite and as you can see here it
takes just seconds to untie it and get
your rope back so you can break down
camp extremely quickly very fast
efficient okay here's another little tip
it's not really a knot but since we're
on the subject of tarps I thought I'd
throw it in here basically pinch a
little loop feed it through the grommet
and then put a stick through it trim it
off there you go
you've now attached your tarp to a
Ridgeline okay and you can just go down
the edge really fast easy way to secure
your tarp so now let me show you the
fisherman's bin or the
grapevine Bend it's a great way of
securing two ropes to each other to
tying dissimilar ropes or even different
size ropes together you tonight this not
by putting what's called a strangle knot
onto one of the ropes and it's also
similar to like a double overhand knot
and you can see here it's pretty simple
pretty fast to tie not too complicated
that's what's the beauty of this knot
it's really simple you just tie that
strangle knot on one side and then you
use the other rope to tie a strangle
knot on the other side and when it's all
done the two knots will slide towards
each other and they'll stop each other
from going any further this is a really
strong way of joining two ropes and it
doesn't take up a lot of rope to tie
this knot once you tighten that it is
not coming off very easily I barely
pulled this together because I wanted my
rope back and I really had to get my
fingernails out to get that knot undone
now here's another knot you need to know
it's the water knot it is the knot for
joining two pieces of nylon strapping
together it's super easy you learn at
once you'll never forget it and it's
basically this just make an overhand
knot and keep it really loose okay nice
and loose plenty gaps and take the
second piece and just follow along and
have it lay right on top of the first
piece of webbing just trace it all the
way through there not there you go
tighten it up BAM that thing is not
common undone like a lot of these bends
yeah it's a little hard to get undone
it's not too bad but once you do it
you'll never forget thanks for watching
I hope you enjoyed this video and learn
something new if you like what you see
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out in multiple videos that we can often
do gear giveaways leave a comment if you
have any questions and see you next time